all right we're starting the week off
with something a little wacky something
i wish we weren't actually having to
start the week off
the new york times uh editorial board
has
written an article called ease up
on the executive actions joe with the
subtitle president biden is right to not
let his agenda be held hostage
but legislating through congress
is a better path and in this article
the new york times editorial board says
correctly that quote
a week into his presidency mr biden has
issued a raft of executive orders and
other actions
already he is committed to rejoining the
paris climate change agreement
ended the muslim travel ban canceled the
permit for the keystone xl pipeline
rescinded funding for and halted
construction
on the wall at the southern border
reaffirmed
the deferred action for childhood
arrivals program
mandated wearing a mask squaring on
federal
grounds moved to end
the federal government's reliance on
private prisons reversed
the ban on transgender military service
and called for agency assessments aimed
at advancing racial equity just to name
a few
the coming days will bring more such
action but this isn't that good
they say and they're concerned they say
not just because executive orders don't
create law
and can be changed by future pres by
future presidents which is true
but because quote um executive actions
are far more ephemeral
and easily discarded than legislation
which can set up a whip saw effect as
each president scrambles to undo the
work of his predecessor
just as mr trump said about reversing as
many of president barack obama's
directives as possible
mr biden is now working to reverse many
of mr trump's reversals with executive
orders there is always another
presidential election just a few years
off
threatening to upend everything this is
one of the silliest new york times
editorials i've seen
first of all these executive orders are
a good
start until permanent legislation can be
passed
if it can and the if right now is
arguably more important than it's ever
been
given that there is a republican party
that doesn't even pretend to care about
policy what
what did marjorie taylor greene run on
other than just trumpism and owning the
libs
what did lauren bobert run on other than
trumpism and owning the libs
this is one of the two-year periods
during which
democrats have control of the house
senate and white house
and they may have no choice but to go at
everything by themselves so we'll talk
more about that
secondly these executive orders are a
signal
that hopefully joe biden is going to do
everything he can
of the things he promised to do
regardless of whether he has republican
support or not and remember
he was elected based on the things he
promised to do and number three
this reeks of status quo ism from the
new york times the new york times
editorial board
doesn't like that joe biden isn't using
the powers he has
after being elected by voters because
it's too much change
what and fourth much of what joe biden
is doing
isn't really a dramatic change anyway
beyond getting us back to the pre-trump
situation so in a way
like i hate to say it but joe biden's
executive orders
are in a sense getting us back to the
status quo
that was the status quo before trump but
the new york times doesn't like it now
hopefully there will be some follow-up
from the new york times editorial board
about how biden can't get a damn thing
done
with republican help uh in the next
three months or six months we'll see
because of their incipient
obstructionism i look forward to the new
york times editorial board
writing that op-ed to provide more
context to this and then just the very
last element of hypocrisy here
there is a general hypocrisy about
biden's
nascent presidency which is that
simultaneously we are hearing biden
hasn't yet done all the stuff he
promised to do
we're 12 days in biden hasn't yet done
it all
but he's also doing too much with too
many executive orders
he's creating too many commissions he's
proposing too many things
come on guys and the the the most
important signal sent by biden's
administration so far based on his
actions
is that he's determined to set the
agenda not mitch mcconnell
and i love that i will and do agree
uh uh i will i i will agree and disagree
better said
with things that joe biden will do but
the fact that joe biden is sending a
signal that it will be his agenda
and not mitch mcconnell's is something i
am very much behind
and you know there are people who are
saying well
joe biden should have worked more with
republicans on some of the things in
those early executive orders
right give me the list of the
republicans that are eager to
reverse the trans military ban who were
the republicans
biden could have worked on with that
would he have had great bipartisan
support
rather than doing that by executive
order instead working with republic give
me a break what republicans were going
to get in line for that
the idea of lecturing biden on using
executive orders
after what the country endured for the
last four years would be hilarious if it
weren't sad
and one really final important element
here
the stuff joe biden is doing via
executive order is really popular
with the people we actually have a list
and when you look at this
you see that banning workplace
discrimination
based on sexual orientation and gender
identity there's 83 percent support
for that okay uh when you look at
committing to a government-wide focus on
racial equity 77
support requiring mass on federal
property 75 percent support
uh continuing suspension of federal
student loan repayments which he did via
eo
68 support and on and on and on
these are popular things were joe biden
pushing through via executive order
things that had 10 support or 15 support
in this country
legally you wouldn't have any different
argument but you would have a stronger
argument that biden is not
ruling by the will of the people he ran
on doing this stuff
this stuff is popular there's no
indication republicans have any interest
in helping joe biden do this stuff
so he's doing popular things he ran on
via executive order give me a break
i hope we'll see a follow-up uh uh
op-ed from the new york times editorial
board providing the context that it was
either do it this way or don't do it at
all and that these things
are popular with americans without that
i don't really even understand the point
of this editorial board piece unless
it's simply just to point to stuff and
say we don't like it
hey this is super interesting last week
we did a piece about the 15
minimum wage which uh which i support
you know i've pointed out
there are parts of the country where 15
is uh almost or even more than a
doubling of the current minimum wage
and it may not be the cost of living
adjusted wage but big picture
i support a 15 minimum wage and we
talked about how
this new radical wacky republican
congresswoman
lauren bobert tweeted about the minimum
wage something really dumb she tweeted
quote
i got my start working at mcdonald's
that job doesn't exist if the minimum
wage is raised to 15 dollars per
hour small business would be crushed by
this arbitrary mandate
and big business would simply automate
away jobs not everything that sounds
good is actually good in practice
and what is fascinating is that now
it just so happens that the company she
mentioned mcdonald's has put out a
statement about this mcdonald's ceo
chris kamzinski
did a fourth quarter earnings call with
investors
um on thursday after we had covered this
story
and he said the company is doing just
fine
in states that have increased minimum
wages beyond the federal minimum wage
and we are basically going to be fine we
will do just fine
even if minimum wages continue
increasing in a variety of different
states
now kamsinsky wasn't this was a call
with investors the point here is to
reassure
investors it's not that kamzinski wants
higher minimum wages it's not that
mcdonald's is now
on for the fight for 15 or this is
merely
a ceo talking to investors and saying
listen
29 states already have higher wages than
the federal minimum
and we're doing just fine and this is
what a four-year analysis by a team of
economists
found for mcdonald's that in applicable
markets where wages have gone up and as
i talked to you about before
dc is already 15 bucks an hour
mcdonald's is doing fine
california's 13 to 14 an hour mcdonald's
is doing fine in california
uh washington state is i believe it's
1369.
mcdonald's is doing fine in washington
state and on and on and on
he was just reassuring investors of what
we already know
and um it is true it is
true that when the minimum wage goes up
the cost of products go up but this is
the this is such a key finding
the study found that when uh the
the minimum wage goes up 10 the cost of
a
of a big mac goes up 1.4 percent
why would it be that if you have a
bigger increase to the wage the cost of
the food only goes up a tiny bit
it's because just as i said last week
labor
is only a fraction of the total cost
you've got
rent for these really expensive uh
locations
that mcdonald's often operate out of
you have the cost of all of the capital
you have
the cost of the food itself you have
insurance you have all these different
things and yes you have labor
and what we again learn
is that labor is only one input and you
can do
wage increases that are meaningful to
the employees
and they have only a minor impact on the
cost of a big
of a big mac now clueless people
like lauren bobert have been able to
scam their way into positions of
legislative power
by attaching themselves to really bad
ideas not based in science
like if the minimum wage goes from 8 to
10
then that's 25 that means the food will
all cost 25 percent more and suddenly
tons of people can't afford the food
that's not the reality the reality is
that meaningful
minimum wage increases will have a tiny
effect on the food which yes
the food will be a tiny bit more
expensive
but way more employees now have money
with which they can go to other local
businesses and buy things that's called
demand side
stimulus so uh nothing of what i'm
telling you today is new
we did this analysis last week but
hearing it
straight from the horse's mouth the
mcdonald's ceo saying
we've done the analysis we have 29
states where minimum wages have gone up
it's fine it's fine and it leads to this
tiny tiny increase to the cost of a
big mac now i know that there will be
the thousand dollar an hour trolls as i
call them but
but david if fifteen dollars is better
than eight
why not pay everybody a hundred dollars
an hour
if more money is good pay everybody
a thousand dollars an hour well no a
thousand dollars an hour is not
a cost of living equilibrium minimum
wage
a thousand dollars an hour is not an
industry balanced minimum wage
there is no metric that justifies a
thousand dollars an hour for people
working at mcdonald's
it is not a productivity adjusted wage
it is not an inflation-adjusted wage
that would not make any sense
if you made the minimum wage at
mcdonald's a thousand dollars an hour
uh you would have doctors in many cases
saying i'm better off working at
mcdonald's
no nobody's saying that we're talking
about 15
some more expensive places in the
country
would justify you know 18 21 in new york
city whatever
nobody's talking about a thousand that's
called reductio ad absurdum
uh it's a slippery slope it's a red
herring it's a lot of different things
so um again a lot of what i'm saying
here
we said last week but now even the
mcdonald's ceo
when the ceo reassures investors we're
doing fine with higher minimum wages
you know that they're doing fine with
higher minimum wages so we'll keep
talking about this and this is part of a
bigger
focus that i think it's important to
have on workplace
issues democratization of the workplace
gig economy stuff i read some
interesting articles over the weekend
about different issues facing gig
economy workers and how
uh tech companies that uh uh are
sort of exhibiting predatory behavior or
taking advantage of them we're gonna
keep talking about this
but as a baseline we have to first build
kind of the base of the pyramid
a lot of the stuff being said by the
right about the minimum wage
is merely disinformation not supported
by left wing or even many right-wing
economists and we'll have more about it
send me your thoughts i'm on twitter at
d pacman we will take a quick break and
be back after this it's february it's
incredibly february
and uh much to discuss today the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is independent
media we have no
money growing on trees we have no big
corporate funders we're mostly funded by
viewers
and podcast listeners who like what we
do enough
uh to sign up at joinpakman.com i invite
you to do so we do a daily extra bonus
show
just for our paid subscribers and we do
have a great coupon code available if
the normal
membership rates should strike you as
too high
that's okay you can use the coupon code
better21 to get a beautiful discount off
of the cost
of a membership one of the things we've
been following
since the january 6th trump riots has
been
the involvement of law enforcement
and or military in the riots and we now
are starting to see
numbers attached to this that are not
particularly
reassuring about the u.s military active
military personnel and veterans
are over-represented looking at the
first 150 arrests
and records released about what took
place on january 6th
cnn did an analysis of pentagon records
and court proceedings
and found that 14
of the first 150 arrests
are of current or former members of the
u.s
military that's more than double the
proportion
of service men and women in the
population
that's calculated based on census bureau
and department of defense
statistics back in 2018 there were 1.3
million active duty members of the
services and 18 million
veterans together that's 5.9 percent of
the population
and yet 14 of those arrested are members
uh current or former of some branch of
the u.s
military uh two of those are army
two are national guard of the 17
veterans six are former army eight or
former marines
two are former navy one was in the air
force at least one served in vietnam
others tended to be deployed to
afghanistan and iraq which makes sense
from the standpoint of
age at least one earned a purple heart
discharged at a variety of ranks and
included
officers as well a captain and a
lieutenant colonel
so there's a few different issues here
first of all
just from like a very abstract
historical standpoint if you're at all
familiar with roman history
there's sort of like a classic roman
historical idea
of disgruntled soldiers supporting
their leader their emperor for a coup
attempt and so
i don't know that we need to go the
whole sort of sort of poetic
route with this or or historical
analogies but they are certainly there
and it's not
an unprecedented thing um one question
i have is this particular study from
pentagon data done by cnn is military
current and former
if we were to say military and law
enforcement
i wonder where the number goes to from
14
that's that's one question but this is a
well-known
sort of historical element that that
repeats itself and to be very clear
this isn't about saying troops are bad
as people
in principle there are i mean listen you
can even say that these are victims
right if you
understand the idea that there is
a massive adaptation problem for people
post-military service this seems to be
more of a vulnerability when we talk to
i mean i'm not making an analogy here
between
white supremacists and former members of
the military but what i do think is
important to understand is that
after traumatic experiences or during
them people become vulnerable to really
bad ideas and to be sucked in by cults
uh and every former white supremacist
we've talked to
uh every former kkk person we've talked
to has told us essentially the same
story about
they were in a vulnerable place and just
as they fell for the community granted
to them by the ideas of white supremacy
because that's what was going on around
them
they could have been pulled in by a
religion they could have been pulled in
by by almost anything
and we know that there are lots of folks
who uh
serve in the military and they have um
a difficulty adapting to post-military
life
and you could fall into any number of
different things so this is not about
simply saying that the people are bad
people necessarily
uh but there might be some explanation
here as to why the trumpers thought that
if they do the insurrection
and they try to steal the election for
trump that maybe the military would
stand down is it possible because
they themselves as members of the
military current or former
thought that maybe that's something that
would happen that maybe the military
would join them in the insurrection i
don't know
uh i'm thinking out loud here but the
numbers are
are certainly stunning you know more
than a 2x representation
relative to the population of current
and former military
and um i don't i mean you tell me
whether this is too cynical
is it conceivable that they may have
been targeted on social media i mean we
know at this point
the degree to which campaigns can be
targeted to folks
so narrowly on social media is it
possible and i'm merely saying
it's something to look into that there
were uh
campaigns uh awareness campaigns
about the riotous insurrection planned
for january 6th
that were targeted to folks who for
example listed
in their likes u.s marines u.s navy air
force or that listed in current or
former occupations
military it certainly can be done as far
as the technology is concerned
uh so then it just becomes a question as
to whether there was the volition and
the awareness to do it we don't yet know
all the answers but the early numbers
certainly are concerning if nothing else
you may or may not know that a week from
tomorrow february 9th
is the start of the second impeachment
trial of donald trump
remember impeachment happens in the
house i'm still getting emails from
saying david
trump hasn't been impeached yet no no
he's been impeached he was impeached
once
and the senate acquitted him he's now
been impeached a second time by the
house and we don't yet know
how the senate will vote although we
kind of do the senate is in all
likelihood going to vote to acquit
donald trump again
that trial starts a week from tomorrow
february 9th and very bad news for
donald trump
i guess depending on your perspective
all of donald trump's
possible lawyers have quit uh south
carolina lawyer butch bowers
and four other attorneys who had signed
on to represent donald trump
in the second impeachment trial all
abruptly quit
over the weekend this is just days
before the trial is going to start
um trump of course is going to be on
trial for having been impeached for his
role in inciting
the attack on the u.s capitol on january
6th
unbelievable that it's already been
almost a month since that
feels like it was yesterday and uh
donald trump's
office announced late last night that
two
new lawyers are going to be taking over
the defense
the reason we are being told
that trump's up until hours ago legal
team has
quit is that trump reportedly wanted
those lawyers
during trump's defense in the senate to
also make the case that trump actually
won the election now
it's really important to understand what
this means
one defense of trump would be trump
didn't incite a riot
he just didn't incite a right that he
had no responsibility whatsoever
when i hear that trump wants his lawyers
to argue that he actually won the
election
it occurs to me that donald trump wants
to do what's called an affirmative
defense
meaning he isn't going to deny what he's
accused of but he's going to argue it
was justified so
when you're accused of murder for
example
one defense would be i didn't do it i
didn't kill anybody
an affirmative defense would be i killed
them but it was self-defense you're
acknowledging that the literal
act took place but you're arguing it's
not
a uh it's not it's not illegal you
shouldn't be punished for it
because it was a justified self-defense
action if you say to me
trump wants his lawyers to argue he won
the election to me it's sounding like
trump wants the argument to be made
that trump did incite it although i'm
sure they would use other words
but it was justified because trump did
win and they were trying to get back for
trump what was rightfully his
it seems insane to me to make that
argument and it seems donald trump's
legal team what was his legal team up
until last night agrees with that
and they are not willing to participate
in it trump's attorneys initially
planned to focus the strategy
on whether the impeachment is
constitutional
given that donald trump is gone and
what the definition is of incitement and
making the case that donald trump didn't
really incite anything and of course
when donald trump says
claim i won the election that changes uh
significantly donald trump according to
people close to him
was telling his lawyers let's litigate
the voter fraud allegations
let's litigate the 2020 race let's
litigate all the stuff that was
litigated for
really a period of two months starting
right after the november 2020 election
and make it a defense of my actions
rather than an argument about
constitutionality or
or that that kind of defense um this
seems
to have been extremely triggering to
donald trump's lawyers trump spokesman
jason miller
says that the split was mutual between
trump and the attorneys
i don't believe that for two reasons
jason miller lies about everything
and trump doesn't tend to have mutual
splits with people
either they resign or he angrily fires
them
and for that reason it doesn't seem
plausible at all now i love i'm i'm
imagining this
dream idea that trump ultimately can't
get anybody to
stay with him through the trial and that
he ends up representing himself and it
becomes sort of like a cartoonish legal
drama
um i don't think it's going to happen
but can you imagine if trump showed up
and tried to defend himself
uh represent himself the reason i don't
think it will happen isn't because trump
doesn't think he could do a good job
trump's exactly the type of narcissist
that would think he can do a good job
defending himself
i don't think it'll happen because
reports are that trump is very uh
confident that he is not going to be
convicted and he's probably right about
that
and thus he doesn't really think it's
worth putting that much effort into this
he's going to just find some lawyers to
help him
he's not getting convicted anyway so why
uh why worry about it too too much on
the other hand
we know trump often doesn't pay his
lawyers so it seems he'd be well
intentioned or or well situated to hire
the best lawyers that he can
and then simply stiff them like he's
tried to do to most of his lawyers
including reportedly rudy giuliani i
don't know the sad
truth the sort of final thought about
this trump could show up
represent himself admit guilt repeatedly
the senate republican cult still
wouldn't convict donald trump that's how
horrifying the status quo of republicans
in the senate now
is so in a sense trump can do whatever
the hell he wants and he's going to get
away with an acquittal
we'll be covering it uh we will also
have more uh coverage
about the lead-up including about donald
trump's lawyers
on the david pakman show instagram make
sure you're following us there at david
pakman show
and follow me on instagram at david.pac
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is audience
supported media
and you can contribute any amount you
want on patreon
as little as one dollar per month plus
you can get the daily
bonus show world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
welcome back to the david pakman show
so unfortunately you know i i didn't
realize
um on november you know eighth
that this outrageous slate
of radical republican members of
congress were going to be
playing such a damaging role in the
national discussion and within the house
of representatives
i certainly knew they were wacky i
certainly knew they were radical i
certainly knew they were ignorant but
i didn't expect that they would become
this weaponized so quickly
and today we're going to talk a little
bit about uh radical congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
now marjorie taylor green we spoke about
last week
as a reminder marjorie taylor green a
republican uh
is a new a q anon conspiracy theorist
um and uh she believes that uh the the q
anon stuff is worth listening to
she has previously said muslims don't
belong in government and swearing on the
quran is not allowed
she has made claims about 9 11 that are
certainly
very very far from what we know to be
the facts which we'll talk about a
little bit later
she has talked about the possibility of
staged elements of the parkland sandy
hook in las vegas shootings and also
harassed
david hogg one of the students who was
a student at marjory stoneman high
school
stone stoneman stoneham i always forget
stoneman
in parkland florida and she has also uh
previously posted on her facebook pages
that democratic officials should be
executed
well there has now been a um
facebook post from two years ago
uncovered whether where marjorie taylor
green
appears to be talking about some kind of
secret jewish controlled space laser
that may be responsible for wildfires
let's take a look at it this is from
november of 2018
where green said i'm posting this in
speculation because there are too many
coincidences to ignore
and just putting it out there from some
research i've done by the way what these
people define as research is often funny
from my curiosity over pg e stocks which
tanked all week then rallied thursday
night
after california official announced they
would not let pg
e fail i find it very interesting that
roger kimmel on the board of directors
of pg e
is also vice chairman of rothschild inc
international investment banking firm uh
oh
i also find it interesting the long
history of financial contributions that
pg e has made to jerry brown over the
years millions spent in lobbying
what a coincidence it must be that
governor brown signed a bill in
september of 2018
protecting pg e and allowing pg e to
pass office
most of fire responsibility to its
customers in rate hikes and through
bonds
it also must be just the coincidence
that the fires are burning
in the same projected areas that the 77
billion dollar high-speed rail project
is being built
is to be built which also happens to be
governor brown's pet project
and what are the odds that feinstein's
husband
another another jewish person richard
bloom
another jewish person is the contractor
on the rail project geez with that much
money we could build three southern
border walls
then oddly there are all these people
who have said they saw what looked like
lasers or bluebee beams of light
causing the fires and pictures and
videos
i don't know anything about that but i
find it really curious
pg e's partnership with solarin
on space solar generators starting in
2009
they announced the launch into space in
2018
maybe even put them up before that space
solar generators collect the sun's
energy and beam it back to earth
to a transmitter to convert to
electricity the idea is clean energy to
replace
coal and oil if they are beaming the
sun's energy back to earth
i'm sure they wouldn't ever miss a
transmitter receiving station right
i mean mistakes are never made when
anything new is invented
what would that look like anyway a laser
beam or light beam coming down to earth
anyway this goes on and on and on and of
co
of course the rothschild family has
featured very heavily in anti-semitic
conspiracy theories for a long time
anti-semites recently often replaced
rothschilds with
george soros that's a that's a
replacement jewish
element to anti-semitic theories and of
course dianne feinstein and her husband
richard bloom it's all
very very jewish oriented as you can see
and um you know one of the really
concerning things is it's not just
that they aren't denouncing marjorie
taylor greene on the republican side
they actually seem to be welcoming her
and lauren beaubert
and madison cawthorne and others is this
the new republican party
like it's after trump but it's not
really post
trump the question was would the would
the the strong
center of the republican party become
trumpy or would they say trump is gone
these people have to go
will they still simply welcome anyone
that will go along with their tax cuts
no matter how insane and that includes
marjorie taylor greene i don't know the
answer
it's still early but so far there
doesn't seem to be any big
rush among the republican establishment
to say these people are nuts and they've
got to go
uh remember that when when they say that
oath all enemies foreign and domestic
isn't marjorie taylor green an example
of a domestic enemy we should be
protected from and not the type of
person that should be protecting or
claiming to protect anybody from
anything
and we're going to be talking about that
more generally
but unfortunately it doesn't end there
with marjorie taylor green
we now have video of marjorie taylor
green
this new wacky republican congresswoman
q anon congresswoman of
jewish space lasers fame there is video
of her
from a week before election day she sat
down
with a pro-gun activist named
chris dorr this was broadcast on
facebook
from a pennsylvania gun shop and this is
a 22-minute interview
posted by the pennsylvania firearms
association
and marjorie taylor green and the gun
shop owner i'm sorry the gun activist at
the gun shop
talked about the second amendment how
important it is to back donald trump
how important it is to back other
far-right republicans
in the election and green warned
that socialists must be fended off
socialists like
joe biden who i can't imagine anything
socially i can't remember
a single socialist idea joe biden has
put forward they would take everybody's
guns and on
and on and she appeared to support
political violence by saying
you only get your freedoms back with the
price
of blood that's the key part and we'll
look at a little bit of this beyond that
but that key part about the price of
blood is right at the beginning
but here's the deal if this generation
doesn't stand up and defend freedom it's
gone
yeah and once it's gone freedom doesn't
come back by itself
the only way you get your freedoms back
is it it's earned with the price of
blood
we we can't be too busy or too
complacent or too worried about
offending someone
anymore it's there's no more excuses
this is this is it november 3rd
freedom is on the ballot you have a
choice of either voting
for freedom by voting for donald j trump
for president again for four more years
voting republicans straight down your
ballot or you're going to vote
for socialism and vote to completely
end america as we know it and this is
this is no joke they do not want you to
be able to defend yourself
because if you can defend yourself guess
what then you can
stop a tyrannical government however if
they take away your guns
then you can't not only can you never
stop a tyrannical government
you can never even defend yourself if
someone is breaking in your home
and and that's the reality this is where
we are today in 2020.
so freedom comes back only
with the price of blood they
i guess democrats don't want you to be
able to
defend yourself so supportive
of violence to achieve political goals
and then also in another prior clip
um on 911 claims there's no evidence
that a plane actually crashed into the
pentagon on 911
a uh unfortunately relatively
uh significantly repeated conspiracy
theory here is marjorie taylor greene
a uh literal 911 truther now in the
house of representatives
barack obama becomes president in 2008
okay um by that time in our american
history
we had had george bush for eight years
we
9 11 sorry about that guys call came in
so i had to decline it
um but we had witnessed 9 11 right we
had witnessed 911
uh the terrorist attack um in new york
and the plane that uh crashed in
pennsylvania
and the so-called plane that crashed
into the pentagon
it's odd there's never any evidence
shown for a plane in the pentagon
but anyways i won't i'm not going to
dive into the 911 conspiracy
she won't dive into it she'll merely
mention it offhandedly oh okay all right
this is a certifiably sick woman don't
we need
to be giving psych evals to run for
congress don't don't we need to do
something
create some basic uh battery of tests
for uh establishing a fundamental basic
level of fitness to be a member of the
house of representatives or the u.s
senate
but of course the problem isn't just the
candidates and i know that many of you
will often focus only on one side or the
other yes
the the fact that marjorie taylor green
is a candidate
is a problem but if nobody was willing
to vote for her we wouldn't be
needing to worry about it i've said this
about trump
if no one fell for trump if the
republican primary voters weren't wacky
enough to fall for trump
trump saying i'm running wouldn't really
matter the bigger problem
is that so many people said yes this is
who i'm choosing and i know
that there are some who will say well
it's because the democrats didn't put up
something better no no no
the democrats did the democrats may not
have put up exactly what we wanted
but the democrats put up something
better uh and uh the the problem is
really bigger than any one thing i was
thinking back yesterday as i was
preparing the story remember when sarah
palin was the craziest person in the
republican party
things have escalated very very quickly
and
i don't know why marjorie taylor green
remains in congress even one more minute
every republican lawmaker should be put
on camera and asked
why don't these comments uh warrant
an immediate expulsion from the house of
representatives
on the bonus show today we'll be talking
about why
it's not even likely she will be a spell
expelled maybe censured
but very unlikely to be expelled more on
that
on the bonus show we'll take a quick
break and be back with much more
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
did you know the david pakman show is on
all sorts of different platforms find us
on youtube
at youtube.com forward slash the david
pakman show
and on steemit the blockchain based
publishing platform
at steemit.com david pakman
that's s t double e m i t dot com
forward slash at david pakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
over the last few years we followed i
was going to call it the evolution it's
really the
the devolution of a fox host maria
bartoromo as i've told you many times
before
way back in um uh when was it way back
in
i guess it was the late 90s when i got
into stocks and
stock markets she was a really good
reporter on cnbc and did a lot of really
interesting things including reporting
from the floor of the new york stock
exchange
during the trump era maria devolved into
the biggest brown-nosing uh
trump sycophant uh perpetuator and
signal booster
of uh un completely uh not based in any
evidence conspiracy theories about the
election
and so much more and she is not stopping
we were wondering with trump gone
whether she would stop because there's
no more
president to keep a relationship with
but she's not stopping here's maria this
weekend
saying that in her view the big lie is
not
that uh joe biden didn't steal
the election the big lie was the entire
russia story
take a listen to this many people still
believe that there was collusion because
of the
incredible way that they were able to
spread this lie
they're calling election fraud the big
lie in my view
this is the big lie russia collusion
with trump
here is maria bartoromo again playing up
the idea
that joe biden is doing something
wrong by not doing the things
trump would have done if he were still
president and she cites
as an example trump was about to put
these are my words now his disgraced
former campaign manager corey
lewandowski
on the defense advisory board something
corey lewandowski
has no business being involved in biden
put a stop to that
for maria that's proof that joe biden is
doing something wrong
i have a book deal you can't come and
speak at harvard
you're import your point of view doesn't
matter and will not be heard in the
public square
you worked at the pentagon cash and now
we know that the pentagon
has stopped political appointments for
any trump allies to join defense
advisory boards
it was supposed to be that corey
lewandowski and david bossie were going
to be joining
the defense advisory board that's been
shelved
they can no longer do it and the
pentagon is stopping anybody
associated with trump from joining these
advisory boards
this is something called elections have
consequences
corey lewandowski on the defense
advisory board
is nuts it never made sense
joe biden rightly put a stop to that
because he won
the election imagine if joe biden won
and didn't say corey lewandowski on the
defense advisory board
sure let's let it happen it would be
outrageous if biden didn't stop that
then maria interviewed former
trump adviser stephen miller an
extraordinarily reactionary right-winger
who points to senator josh hawley
losing a book deal with a private book
publisher as being evidence i guess
of joe biden being bad first of all
president biden has missed a historic
opportunity
to make good on this pledge to be a
president for all americans and to stand
up and say the censorship must stop
the black listing must stop we have to
listen to and respect all viewpoints in
america
but he has not done that he has turned a
blind eye to it
and what you see when you see people
being denied book deals when you see
people
being denied contracts when you see
people being banned off of twitter
and facebook and other platforms what
you are seeing is a fundamental erosion
of the concept of liberty and freedom in
america the censorship
the erosion of liberty and freedom first
of all simon and schuster
saying we don't want to publish josh
hawley's book
is merely a private company deciding
what's profitable for them that's
something the right claims to support
but more outrageously holly lost his
book deal
while trump was president trump was
banned from twitter
while trump was still president none of
those things were done
while joe biden was president so
obviously at its face these are not
examples of censorship
these are not examples of anything other
than companies deciding what's good for
them
and while they're not assuming they're
not violating any laws
they are acting on that acting on their
terms of service etc
but the really wacky aspect is it all
happened while trump was president why
why are we even talking about joe biden
one more clip maria bartoromo continues
to platform
deception about what free speech and
censorship even are
concept of liberty and freedom in
america freedom's not just a line on a
piece of paper maria
freedom is a culture freedom is a way of
life freedom is a way of being
if we as americans get to the point
where we're willing to discriminate
against people
based on their point of view being a
republican democrat conservative liberal
we have fundamentally abandoned our core
values and you're right it's going to
lead to
we're not going to bank with you we're
not going to give you a mortgage we're
not going to lease you a car
we're not going to represent you in a
court of law there's no limiting
principle here
this could not be more important please
come back we'll continue our conference
super important stephen yes please come
back and tell us more about that
now the problem isn't just these shows
it's that people thinking they're
learning something here
what i mean by that is the following if
people were more educated and media
literate
they would know i'm not going to learn a
damn thing about censorship and free
speech in the first amendment on fox
news
sunday morning from maria bartoromo and
stephen miller
if people were more aware and and
conscious of this being it's it's really
it's just entertainment and it's really
not that entertaining it's entertainment
for some people
they might understand oh you know if i
want to read about constitutional law
let me go get the book of erwin
chemerinsky a constitutional law scholar
and professor that we interviewed on the
show
or if you really want to learn about the
first amendment you go and you read the
work of bert newborn the new york
university law
professor expert on the first amendment
who we interviewed on the program
if you understand what is actual
expertise on the
these issues and you realize the
expertise on the first amendment and
censorship it's not coming
from uh uh stephen miller it's not
coming from maria bartoromo
this stuff wouldn't be as dangerous
unfortunately
a lot of people don't know or don't care
to find
uh actual experts on those issues so
they watch
fox news and they hear stephen miller
talk about
censorship and suppression of speech
because simon and shuster said we're not
going to publish a book for example
and they think that they're actually
learning something that's a systemic
problem that's a cultural problem that's
an educational problem
i have warned everyone that we are going
to be seeing
an explosion of radicalization through
right-wing media during these next two
years i've been saying for months now
that trump's insanity is going to be
replaced by right-wing media insanity
and that will include fox news having to
do something wacky
to get an audience back from newsmax and
oan
but it will likely also include newsmax
and oan
going even more extreme now that donald
trump is gone and we haven't had to wait
even a minute to see it
newsmax host chris salcedo i actually
appeared on this guy's old radio show
some years ago
chris salcedo claims that democrats are
pushing us towards civil war let's take
a look and then discuss
in my opinion democrats dangerous
rhetoric their vacuous charges and
feigned fear
are pushing america toward a civil war
the question remains
why many on the republican side have
noted on many occasions that democrats
have disarmed their voters through
irrational fears of
firearms those same republicans
rationalize they would be foolhardy
for democrats to pick a civil war fight
that they would sure assuredly lose
but the democrats wouldn't be alone now
can you folks think of a nation on the
planet earth that would benefit from
be elated by or pushing for an american
civil war i can't that's right
joe biden's buddies china if america is
pushed into a civil war by the democrats
that will benefit the world's most
inhuman racist
slave state china the policy course
sorted by
socialist democrats is counter to
american freedom liberty and prosperity
their rhetoric may threaten our very
existence the republic
itself someone should wake up mitt
romney pat toomey and ben sasse
i know i know you you might be saying
wait a second hold on
wasn't it trump and don jr
and rudy giuliani and marjorie taylor
green and lauren beaubert who were
pushing us closer to civil war
by fomenting and inciting an armed
insurrection to try to keep the guy who
lost in power
does this guy chris salcedo not remember
that it was
armed violent republicans that stormed
the capital weeks ago
but chris salcedo says it's democrats
pushing us towards civil war
wasn't it republicans who for two months
hesitated to even admit that joe biden
had won the election
threatening the very basic institutions
of democracy but it's democrats that are
pushing us towards civil war
and democrats that are putting our
country at risk of not being a
democratic country
the people who draped themselves in the
confederate flag
which represents literally the loser in
the civil war
stormed the capital to try to overturn
the results of an election
and they are now the ones saying
democrats are pushing
us to civil war how can this be now the
one funny thing
there isn't there isn't much funny about
this but there is one funny part
newsmax guy says democrats are pushing
us to civil war
but they would lose because they don't
have weapons because they're against
guns
newsmax guy seems to think that if there
were
such a civil war it would be republican
citizens
versus democratic citizens just like
random voters
fighting with handguns and rifles in the
streets the reality is that in such a
civil war
that was started by these
insurrectionists most americans would be
staying at home and it would be the
insurrectionists versus the full power
of the us government and military
so the idea that biden and democrats
would lose
is very funny but i don't even want to
focus on that
because it is so unbelievably absurd but
the bottom line here
is that democrats are not the ones
inciting
a civil war fomenting a civil war
or demanding a civil war newsmax oan
and others that are broadcasting and
promoting disunity and conspiracies
while perpetuating the election fraud
lies
are the ones pushing us closer to civil
war i don't think it will happen for a
variety of different reasons
but if it were to it's not going to be
republican and democratic voters
fighting it out with handguns
and as we've talked about before
geographically that also doesn't make
sense since increasingly you know we
talk about red and blue states
but really what we have are uh urban
areas
and even suburban areas which are uh
heavily and leaning more to the left
in states that may be blue states or red
states with significantly more red
rural counties around them so all of the
language they're using about civil war
is wrong
all of the framing they're using about
civil war is wrong but the idea that
it's democrats fomenting it
doesn't pass the sniff test as you've
heard me say before
hey um i i've gotten uh i've got an
interesting voicemail to play for you
you can leave a voicemail anytime at 219
to david p it's about a wacky
congresswoman
lauren bobert and uh her education
and or lack thereof and there's a few
things here i want to talk about so
let's listen
uh good evening david uh my name is ray
i'm calling in regards to congresswoman
bobart
uh i was doing some research on her and
i stumbled across the fact that
she received her ged not her high school
diploma
in may of 2020 right yet her
office and her people have not confirmed
nor denied
that she received it nor if she even has
one so there seems to be something not
right with that
um based on the fact that if she had
received it in may
you know they would have to basically
just say yeah this happened and
that's okay but they seem to not even
want to address it which could
mean to me possibly that she doesn't
even have one
so maybe that's something that our
viewers can dig deeper into this
and uh and just find out what's going on
with this person
because she she's totally unfit to be in
congress so
yeah now so listen a lot of what the
caller says is correct lauren bobert is
completely unfit to be in congress it's
not because she doesn't have a high
school diploma or college education
necessarily she's unfit because
she's a radical insurrectionist and part
of the problem we're trying to solve
rather than any possible solution
now in terms of the ged stuff the caller
is correct
it is asserted that lauren beaubert got
her ged that the story of lauren
beaubert is something like and i'm
paraphrasing here
she was in high school but she dropped
out to work at mcdonald's
i don't remember if it was to support
her family or or what what the the
reasoning was
and then she later went back and got her
ged uh a few months ago reportedly
getting it in may of 2020.
i have no idea it it's i've not seen
what we might call proof that she really
got her ged
she may have it she may not but but
here's the thing this is not about
education shaming lauren beaubert is an
ignorant person regardless of what kind
of degree she has
a year ago i met someone with a phd in
biology
who maybe when it came to biology was an
absolute genius
but was a complete and total idiot when
it came to
political science economics
cultural issues sociology i mean it was
just
i i felt like i was talking to someone
who who uh seemed to lack
education altogether so you know when it
comes to biology maybe this person was
great maybe not
having or not having a ged high school
diploma college degree master's degree
phd it is not proof that you are or
aren't fit
to be an elected official um the sad
truth is that whether lauren beaubert
does or doesn't have a ged
she is not someone that should be
involved in making law or leading the
country whatsoever now on the other hand
bill gates dropped out of college
he's more than well qualified to be a
member of congress or senator
he understands the scientific method he
understands how to think about problems
he understands how to manage people and
projects and on and on and on and so for
me the problem is
that for some of these folks the lack of
education has become sort of a point of
pride where voters
are drawn to someone because they've
fallen for this idea that higher
education is a
liberal indoctrination conspiracy theory
thing and they
they seem to think that by electing
someone who's not gone to college
that they're owning the libs in some way
i think it's important that we on
the left don't focus on education
shaming
there are plenty of people without uh
significant degrees of formal education
who are very smart and would be great
leaders for this country
and that would be fantastic and as i've
said before in general we should be
diversifying the types of folks that
represent us we don't want just
former lawyers and former ceos
and career politicians i would love
teachers
i would love people from science i would
like people for
you know on and on and on but the
idea of going to people without formal
education
merely because you think education is
liberal indoctrination is a problem
and so uh if if lauren beaubert is lying
about her ged that's a major problem
if lauren beaubert is unfit to be a
member of congress
because of her ideas and and the fact
that she brings no
knowledge whatsoever about policy and
that's the case
she shouldn't be in the house of
representatives and she shouldn't but i
think we need to look more deeply
much the same way as trump as a can
trump if trump had run as a democrat
he'd have had no shot of winning the
primary
and trumpism wouldn't be what it is
trumpism is what it is because trump ran
as a republican and the republican
electorate fell
for it slash liked it slash was drawn to
it partially to quote own the libs as
they would often say
and so a lot of the problem is the
electorate the electorate that sees
someone as incompetent as lauren bobert
and regardless of her formal education
level says
let's choose her that's what we need to
solve that's a bigger cultural issue
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about the republican
counteroffer to biden's covid19 bill
and much much more become a member and
get instant access
at joinpakman.com